ก็สวัสดีครับขอเรียนดีค่ะครูนี้โอเคแล้ว
ก็สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนว่าดีค่ะนักเรียน
นักเรียนเป็นยังไงบ้างคะวันนี้
เป็นยังไงบ้างคะวันนี้วันนี้เนี่ยโอเค
สบายดีครับใช่
คุณเรียมสบายดีไหมเตรียมสบายดีค่ะเหมือน
ครูนิคบอกว่าคนนี้สบายดีแล้วก็หรือ
ไม่เพราะว่าเมื่อกี้เนี่ยคุณนี้กาดกิน
เหมือนเกิดกิน Pepsi แล้วมันมีลม
แก๊สมีลงรมณีย์แก๊สนิดหน่อยช่วยเป็นเคย
ติดออกเฮ้ยไม่งั้น The ให้เสียงฮ่าๆๆโอเค
แล้ว
วันนี้ที่เราคุยกันในวันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
แม่ของครูนิคนะวันศุกร์ครับวันศุกร์แถว
เดอะมอลล์เอาวันตามครูนิคนะ
วันศุกร์วันศุกร์พรุ่งนี้อยู่ที่ไหนคะวัน
ศุกร์ของครูเล็กเนี่ยคืออยู่ที่อเมริกาก็
คือวันศุกร์ที่ 9 ขอวันศุกร์ที่ 9 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือนกันยายนครับฮือปีพตต
ปีพ.ศ.
2565 ออใช่
ทีเดียวกันใช่ไหม
ขอบคุณเล็กช้ากว่าแค่ช้าชั่วโมงนะไม่ช้า
เป็นปี rr5 ๆเขียนพฤหัส
โหแล้วก็ปีคศอะไรนะคะที่ข้อ
2022 ครับ r22 ที่อเมริกากี่โมงคะพรุ่ง
นี้ตอนนี้นะครับที่อเมริกาเนี่ยเวลา
09:30  4 นาทีน 9:30  4 นาทีอูก็ดึกแล้ว
นะเออก็นิดนึงครับ
อ๋อโอเคแต่ก็คุยได้ใช่ไหมคะครูนี้ก็ยัง
ไม่ง่วงยังไม่ง่วงยังไม่ง่วงแต่ตาปิดละ
แต่ยังไม่ง่วงหรือว่าถ้าเกิดเรียมเล่า
นิทานให้ฟังนะรู้นี้ก็คงจะหลับก็พอเล่า
เสร็จแล้วก็คุณนี่ก็เข้าห้องนอนเลยไม่นอน
เลยใช่ค่ะโอเคคุณมีไปนอนก่อนก็ได้นะลืมจะ
ได้เล่าไปด้วย
โอเคได้ครับสวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
น่ะลาคนนี้ก่อนนะคะนักเรียนตอนนี้นัก
เรียน 1 วงแล้วนะว่าเอ๊ะทำไมถึงบอกแค่วัน
ที่เราก็ไปแล้วไปเลยไปนอนนะถ้าซื้อก็คือ
วันนี้ลืมจะมีเรื่องเรื่องนึงมันเล่าให้
ครูนี้ฟังโอเคเรื่องอะไร
มันเป็นเรื่องของสัตว์
สัตว์ที่อยู่ในบ่อน้ำ
คือเวลาที่กรูนึกครูนิรุนิกส์นึกถึงคุณ
นึกละนะครูนิดนึกถึงหม้อน้ำ 5 รูนี้จะนึก
ถึงอะไรบ้าง
อย่างราบเนี่ยก็ต้องเป็นปลา
ใช่
อย่างใช่ปลาว่ายน้ำอย่างที่สองเนี่ยก็จะ
ต้องเป็นกบอ๋อมีกบใช่ๆเออเราก็มีปูปูใช่
ไหมคะ
กูเนี่ยรสปูเนี่ยมันจะอยู่ตามงั้นบนทะเล
มากกว่าน่าจะมักคือสำหรับคนนี้นะแค่คุณ
นี้จะเห็นปูเวลาผู้ชายหาดบนทรายที่เหมือน
กับเดิมๆแต่แค่ไม่เคยเห็นปูที่อยู่ในน้ำ
จริงคือเทพในทีวีที่เป็นเหมือนปูอลาสก้า
ว่าตัวใหญ่ๆเหอะเหอะ
ก็จริงอ่ะเนาะถ้าอยู่ในบ่อน้ำปูก็อยู่ใน
บ่อน้ำได้นะกูนิ่งๆโจ๊กคิดว่าน่าจะใช่อาจ
จะเป็นเหมือนกับ
ปูเค็มที่เค้าไปทำส้มตำปูเค็มใช่ป่ะ
ปูน้ำจืดน้ำจืดก็มีนะปูนา
poona เนี่ยเขาจะมีเขาจะมีรูเขาจะเข้าไป
อยู่ในรูอยู่ใกล้ๆกะบ่อน้ำ
แต่เขาจะไม่ได้อยู่ในน้ำ 24 ชั่วโมง
นั่นแหละแต่เขาก็ลงไปในน้ำได้เดินๆในน้ำ
ได้นะ
ใช่เดินได้จริงๆนะเพราะว่าจริงๆเหมือนกับ
เห็นในทีวีอยู่ในการ์ตูนมันก็มีนะที่อยู่
ในน้ำนั่นแหละใช่ใช่ๆนั่นแหละพิมพ์กำลัง
จะเล่าถึงว่า
มันจะมีทั้งปลาปูกลมอยู่ในบ่อน้ำแห่ง
หนึ่งแต่ว่าบ่น้ำอ่ะกูนี้มันไม่ได้ใหญ่
เหมือนทะเลนะครับมันเล็กนิดเดียว
ใช่ถ้าเกิดร้อนๆเหมือนประเทศไทยเนี่ยแล้ว
ฝนไม่ตกอ่ะมันจะเป็นยังไงคะ
เจอะนะร้อนๆส่วนไม่ตกสวยมันก็ไม่มีน้ำไง
เห้ยน้ำมันก็จะน้อยลงมันน้อยลง
ใช่ค่ะน้อยลงแล้วถ้าเกิดน้ำน้อยลงเนี่ย
ปลาก็อยู่ไม่ได้นะลาก็ก็อาจจะอยู่ในน้ำ
แต่ว่าอาจจะอาจจะ
กรอบนี้มีกรอบตายฉันแห้งดอกตาไปนอนตายอาจ
จะดิ้น
แล้วนะเรื่องเนี้ยก็จะมีนกกระยางนกกระยาง
นกกระยางเดี๋ยวนะนกกระยางขึ้นรกที่ขายยาว
ๆใช่ไหมใช่ใช่สุนกที่ขายยาไหว้ครูนิคเห็น
ที่ไหนคะนกกระยาง
คุณนี่เห็นที่ไหนก็
เดี๋ยวนะคุณไม่เคยเห็นนกนกกระยาง
ในก็เห็นในการ์ตูนนะใช่ใช่ตัวนี้ครับก็
เห็นในการ์ตูนที่ว่าใช่นกอย่างที่เขาจะมา
ก่อนที่เค้าเหมือนก็จะเอาเด็กไปส่งตาม
บ้านใช่มั้ย
น้องก็อยากไปส้มโออ่าอันนี้มันจะเหมือน
เป็นการ์ตูนของฝรั่งที่ว่าเหมือนกับมีนก
แล้วเขาก็จะเอาเด็กแล้วก็บินไปส่งอาร์ม
บ้านเมื่อจะมีการ์ตูน 1 เรื่องใช่
เตรียมน่าจะไม่ได้ดู
หรือว่าแบบอาจจะดูแล้วแบบผ่านมานานหน้า
เครื่องเหมือนกับมันเป็นเหมือนกับสมัย
ก่อนนู้นเลยพี่ว่าเป็นนกกระยางเหมือนกับ
จริงๆก็เหมือนกับเป็นมีเหมือนเกือบแฟน
เหมือนกับผู้หญิงผู้ชายอยากมีลูกแล้วก็ขอ
พระเจ้าว่าอยากมีลูกนิมิตพระเจ้าเขาก็จะ
ส่งรูปมาให้พี่บ้านก็จะเป็นนกกระยางนั่น
แหละดินอ๋อเป็นนกกระยางมาเกิดไม่ก็คือ
เป็นนกกระยางแบบเด็กมาแล้วก็มาส่งที่บ้าน
หนูนกกระยางคงจะตัวใหญ่มากจ๊ะจะตัวใหญ่นะ
แต่เดี๋ยวคนนี้คิดว่าเดี๋ยวคนแต่เดี๋ยว
พรุ่งนี้จะเอารูปให้ดู
[เพลง]
ดึงนึกว่านกกระเรียนคือมันมีหลายนก้อแล้ว
นกกระเรียนน่ะคนนึกว่าจะเป็นตัวตัวเล็กๆ
เหมือนก็ขาขายยาวๆที่สำหรับคุณที่คนนี้
คิดว่านกกระเรียนอ่ะจะคล้ายๆเหมือนกันนก
ฟามิงโก้
อันนี้คือความคิดของคุณนิดนะ
คะเนี่ยศิษย์ที่เน็ตหรือว่าน่าจะเป็นนก
กระเรียนหรือเปล่านี่ไงที่ถ้าเป็นการ์ตูน
และเขาก็จะเป็นเหมือนแบบเนี้ยเห็นไหมครับ
เดี๋ยวนะเห็นรูปมั้ย
อ๋อๆเห็นแล้วค่ะมันก็จะเป็นแบบอย่างเงี้ย
อ๋อเอาเด็กมาให้
ใช่
มันก็จะเหมือนกันอาบในการ์ตูนหรือเป็น
เกี่ยวกับสมัยก่อนอ่ะตัวอย่างนี้ครับอ๋อ
อ๋อมองน้องเห็นนิดนึง
หน้าจอสว่าง
หน้าจอสว่างมากมาเห็นละเห็นละโอเคเห็น
แล้วค่ะกูเธอก็เหมือนกันนะเออถุงเนี่ยก็
คือเป็นเด็กเด็กแรกเกิดเด็กทารกเลย r  o
เขตเตรียมเสียบปลั๊กคอมก่อนในว่าเรียนลืม
เสียบป่า
ได้ได้ครับ
โอเคเดี๋ยวแบตหมดได้แต่จริงๆรบจะเรียนน่ะ
ถ้าส่งรูปได้นะนกกระเรียนก็น่าจะไปส่ง
ข้าวได้นะ
แต่ว่าในเรื่องเนี้ยนกกระเรียนน่ะอาหาร
ของเขาก็คือปลา
นกนะทั่วๆไปก็หลายตัวนะที่กินป่าใช่ใช่
แต่ว่านกตัวนี้เห็นว่าน้ำในบ่อเนี่ยมี
น้อยแล้วเราก็เลยคุยกับปลาในบ่อบอกว่าอ่ะ
รู้ไหมว่าเราอ่ะบินได้แล้วบินไปเห็นบ่อ
น้ำที่อื่นนะที่มันใหญ่มาก
เราอ่ะอยากพาทุกๆคนไปบ่อน้ำบ่อใหม่ครับ
ปลาก็เลยบอกว่าธรรมดานกไม่ได้ใจดีกับปลา
นะเออใช่
แล้วมันกินปลาง่ายคือคุณนิดแบบเป็นปลานะ
คุณนี้ก็จะคิดแล้วเองนกเนี่ยเชื่อได้ไหม
เพราะปกตินกก็กินปลาแล้วบอกว่าจะเอาไป
อยู่ในบ่อน้ำใหม่
มันมีน้ำเยอะกว่า
ฟังดูเรื่อง
แปลกๆนะใช่ปลาก็คิดเหมือนกันว่าฟังดูแล้ว
แปลกๆนะธรรมดาไม่เคยจะช่วยแถมยังจะฆ่า
ไลน์อีกอะและแล้ววันนี้ช่วยเนี่ยมันไม่
ใช่ละไม่เชื่อแต่ว่าน้ำในบ่อมันมีน้อย
จริงๆนะคะครูนี่ปลาก็เลยแบบคิดให้หรือว่า
จะเชื่อนกดีนะ
แต่ถ้าแต่ถ้าเชื่อนกเนี่ยใช่ใช่เขาว่าน้ำ
ได้มันมีน้อยจะได้เชื่อนกเนี่ยก็เราทำนก
โกหกเนื้อปลาก็ตายไวกว่าน้ำมันหมดน่ะแล้ว
ปลาอยู่ในน้ำก็ตายอย่างทรมานนะตัวนี้
เออเกิดเราก็เอาโอเคก็จริงก็จริงครับเรา
ยังไงล่ะปลาเนี่ยเชื่อนกไหม
ปลาก็ก็อีกจะเชื่อหรือไม่เชื่อดีแต่ว่าใน
บ่อน้ำนั้นอ่ะมีปลาอยู่เยอะไม่ได้มีอยู่
ตัวเดียว
เขาก็เลยบอกคุยกันว่าเดี๋ยวจะให้นกเนี่ย
ข่าปลาไป 1 ตัวตัวใหญ่ๆเลยนะคะอย่าฆ่าปลา
ไปจับปลาแล้วก็บินขึ้นไปดูว่ามีบ่อน้ำ
จริงๆไหมฮือโอเคแล้วก็ค่อยกลับมามาที่บ่อ
นี้แล้วก็มาบอกทุกคนน้าโอเคใช่แล้วปลาตัว
ไหนจะไปล่ะเขาก็เลือกแบบปลาตัวใหญ่ๆเออ
ตัวหนึ่งโอเครับเปล่าตัวนั้นเขาไม่กลัว
เหรอปลาตัวนั้นเขาก็กลัวนะแต่ว่าถ้าเกิด
เข้าไปแล้วไม่ได้กลับมาเพื่อนที่อยู่ใน
บ่อก็ไม่ต้องไปเชื่อนก
ใช่แต่
เพราะคุณนี้แหละคิดว่าแล้วทำไมปลายอมยอม
ตายล่ะถ้า
เพื่อนบอกเธอไปในไปดูแล้วเดี๋ยวก็กลับมา
ว่าจริงไหมถ้าคนที่เป็นปลาตัวนั้นนะคนนี้
ก็จะคิดว่า
แล้วถ้านกยิงฉันล่ะฉันก็ต้องอ่าใส่สิครับ
เป็นปลาที่เสียสละมากเลเซอร์หม่ำมากจะให้
คือเสียสละให้ตัวเองโดนกิน
เพื่อนจะได้ไม่โดนพิมพ์เป็นคนเสียสละมากๆ
ใช่ทำเพื่อเพื่อนๆทำเพื่อให้
ใช่ค่ะในขณะที่น้ำในบ่อก็ลดน้อยลงลดน้อย
ลงนะครับแล้วที่นี้นกก็เลยเหมือนเขาฆ่า
ป่าไปมือผ้าป่าแล้วก็บินไป
บินไปแบบวนวนรอบบ่อน้ำใหญ่ครับ
เราก็บินกลับมา
ปลาปลาที่ไปกับน้องก็บอกว่ามันมีบ่อน้ำ
จริงๆทุกคน
จงช่วยไม่โดนกินใช่มั้ยปลาช่อนมาดุอ๋อ
โอเคให้อ่ะดีแล้วที่นี้ทุกคนก็เลยเชื่อ
เชื่อว่าโอเคปลาบอกว่ามีบ่อน้ำ
ก็เลยเชื่อนกด้วยว่านกจะช่วยจริงๆ
หลังจากวันนั้นนกก็บอกว่าเดี๋ยวจะมาฆ่า
ปลาไปที่บ่อน้ำ
แบบที่ละตัวทีละตัวเรื่อยๆครับพรุ่งนี้
คิดว่าปลาทุกตัวไปถึงบ่อน้ำมั้ย
คือคุณนี้ก็คิดว่าปลาทุกตัวไปถึงบ่อน้ำ
เพราะ
เหมือนกับ
เขาว่าเขาเชื่อแล้วว่ามีบ่อน้ำจริงๆแล้ว
เขาก็คิดว่านกอะไม่กินปลาเพราะว่าเพื่อน
ที่เป็นปลาเนี่ยยังกลับมาได้
ทุกคนก็ต้องไปได้เพราะว่าปลาทุกตัวเนี่ย
เชื่อแล้วว่านกอยากช่วยอยากเอาจากบ่อน้ำ
และมีน้ำน้อยมากไปบ่อน้ำมันใหม่ที่มีน้ำ
เยอะ
ใช่ค่ะแต่สิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นหลังจากนั้นก็
คือนกมาฆ่าปลาที่บ่อน้ำแล้วก็บินบินบิน
บินบินไปหยุดที่ต้นไม้
แล้วก็กินปลาเออ
[เพลง]
แล้วก็บินกลับไปที่บ่อน้ำแล้วก็บอกว่าใคร
จะไปที่บ่อน้ำใหญ่
ก็คาบมาที่ต้นไม้แล้วก็กิน
โป๊
แล้ว
คึแบบนี้คุณนี้ก็อยากรู้ว่าแล้วปลาตัว
ใหญ่ที่ไปครั้งแรกเนี่ยโดนกินไหม
ปลาตัวใหญ่ที่ไปครั้งแรกได้กลับมาแต่เวลา
ที่เค้าคาบกับไปอีกก็โดนเมียคุณค่า
ถึงหือโหลนก
มีนกตัวนี้นะนกกระยางอ่ะกินปลาหมดเลยไหม
ใช่ค่ะกินปลาหมดทั้งบ่อเลย
จนจนเหลือแค่ปูปูแค่หนึ่งตัวในบ่อครับนก
ก็อย่างก็คิดว่าเงินปลาก็ไม่มีให้กินแล้ว
ยังไม่ลืมหรอกวันๆเขาก็กินเรื่อยๆเนาะ
เพราะว่ามันผ่านไปแต่ละวันผ่านไปแต่ละวัน
เขากินแล้วเขาก็อิ่มแล้วก็ถ้าหิวหิวแล้ว
ก็แบบกินแล้วก็อิ่มแล้วก็หิวอีก
ใช่แต่ว่าเหลือปูอยู่ตัวเดียวตอนนี้
ทำยังไงหรอก็เลยจะคิดว่าอ่ะโอเคจะกินปู
โอ้โห
กินปูตะปูหรือตัวใหญ่มากๆแล้วปูมันไม่ได้
กินง่ายเหมือนปลานะเพราะมาดูว่ามันมี
เขาเรียกว่าอะไรมันมีกระดองอ่ะเหมือนมัน
มีขึ้นมากินไม่ได้เออมันแข็งๆจังๆมันแข็ง
ๆมันแข็งๆเออนั่นแหละแต่ว่ามันไม่มีอะไร
ให้กินแล้ว
ก็เลยแบบอ้าโอเคเหลือปุ๋ยตัวเดียวก็จะกิน
ปูด้วย
ปูก็แบบไม่ค่อยเชื่อนกตัวนี้นะครับ
ก็เลยบอกว่าเอาอย่างนี้แล้วกันกูเนี่ยตัว
ใหญ่
นกเนี่ยคาบคาบเดี๋ยวข้าไม่ไหวหรอกเดี๋ยว
ร่วงครับก็เลยเดี๋ยวเราจะเอากล้ามปูนก้าม
ปู
หนีบคอนกไว้
แล้วยังไงเชื้อก็เลยแบบโอเคๆไปหนีบคอทบคะ
แล้วก็บิน
โอเค
บินไปบินไปไปถึงบินบินไปถึงที่ต้นไม้ครับ
กูเพื่อเห็นมีก้างปลา
คุณมันจะมีก้างปลาแบบนี้ครับใช่ปางพายุ
เยอะมากเมื่อกี้คนที่จะบอกพี่ป้างกาก้าง
ปลา
มีก้างปลาอยู่เยอะมากกูก็เลยรู้แล้วว่า
เฮ้ยนกเอาปลามากินไม่ได้เอาปลาไปปล่อยที่
บ่อน้ำใหญ่เออ
ลบก็เลยบอกว่าบอกนกกระยางว่าเอาเราไปคืน
ที่บ่อน้ำเอาเราไปส่งที่บ่อน้ำครับถ้าไม่
ไปส่งเนี่ยจะเอาก้ามหนีบคอตาย
แล้วนกกระยางทำยังไงมึงแอบได้ยินละว่าปู
เนี่ยโกรธแล้วก็เห็นมันก็ยังจะต้องโดนกิน
แน่เลยแล้วยังไงเดี๋ยวดิบบีบคออีกแล้วนะ
ครับจะให้ปล่อยให้อีกจะกลับบ่นะอ้ำใช่
แล้วนกกระยางก็บิลไปส่งปูที่บ่อน้ำ
แต่พอถึงบ่อน้ำบลูก็เอาก้ามหนีบขอนกอย่าง
จะแกะต่าย
ใช่พรุ่งนี้คิดว่าแบบเรื่องนี้สอนอะไรเรา
บ้าง
สอนอะไรบ้างก็
จริงๆก็สอนไม่ก็
มันก็สอนเรื่องขับคนถ้าทำดีก็ได้ดีทำไม่
ดีมันก็ได้ไม่ดีกลับมา
ให้ฉา
ไม่
ใช่ใช่แล้วอีกอย่างนึงนะเกี่ยวกับเรื่อง
การไว้ใจคนด้วยเนาะๆใช่พี่แบบตอนแรกเรา
ชื่ออะไรนะ
เขาทำให้ปลาทุกตัวเชื่อว่านกอยากจะช่วย
จริงๆชอบแต่สุดท้ายปลาทุกตัวก็ตายหมดเลย
ไม่ได้กดมาเนี่ย
แสดงว่ามีผีหลอกหรือเปล่า
เป็นผีจับปลาที่โดนลบพยานกิน
ไม่ใช่เราพูดเนี่ยว่าทำดีได้ดีทำชั่วได้
ชั่วแหละปลาก็เลยบอกว่าเยี่ยม
น้ามากดไลค์ได้ปลามาโปรด
ญาติปลาใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ได้
สุดยอดเป็นผีเป็นผีแล้ว 1 ผิวจะทำให้
คอมพิวเตอร์อีกเออ
ได้ก็คนเล็กเนี่ยก็มึงก็เหมือนกับเสื้อมา
ก็เราจะใช้คำว่านกเนี่ยเป็นคนแปลกหน้าก็
ได้นะเหมือนกับถ้าคนที่มันเราไม่เชื่อเรา
ไม่ไว้ใจนะถึงเข้าจะพูดดีแบบไหนแบบดีมากๆ
ฟังแล้วดีมากๆเราก็ต้องคิดเยอะๆว่าจริง
หรือเปล่าเพราะถ้าเชื่อไปมันก็เป็น
อันตรายให้ใช่ค่ะหรือว่าอาจจะมีแบบคิดไว้
ถ้าเกิดเกิดอะไรที่ไม่ดีขึ้นเราจะทำยังไง
ใช่
เพราะว่าบางทีแบบเชื่อ 100% ก็จะเป็นแบบ
นี้
แต่ว่าถ้าเกิดกลัวมากๆก็อาจจะไม่รอด
เหมือนกันนะเธอมากๆไม่ทำอะไร
ชายมันก็ที่มันก็ต้อง
และก็คิดว่าเราต้องระวังแล้วก็อันไหนที่
มันดูแล้วเป็นไปได้มากกว่า
จะทำก็ได้ก็โอเคใช่แต่ต้องระวัง
ใช่จ่ายค่ะก็ประมาณนี้ค่ะคลินิกคิดว่า
หลายๆคนก็อาจจะได้แบบเหมือนแบบแง่คิดหรือ
ข้อคิดดีๆจากเรื่องนี้
ก็เป็นเรื่องจริงๆเด้อที่น่าสนใจนะเป็น
เรื่องที่ตังค์แล้วก็เออมันให้ความคิดมัน
สอนเป็นเรื่องสอนมันจะนิทานสอนนิทานสอนใจ
ใช่ไหมที่คนไทยจะชอบกวนใจใช่ไหมคติสอนใจ
สิสอนใจเป็นเพื่งที่เอามาสอนใจว่าทำแบบ
นี้ดีทำแบบนี้ไม่ดี
เราก็เลือกเชื่อเหมือนเล่าให้มันเป็น
ประสบการณ์ของเราเนาะเวลาเจอเรื่องจริงก็
ไม่รู้ว่าอะไรควรทำยังไงดีใช่ใช่ใช่ค่ะ
ประมาณนี้ค่ะครูนิให้โอเคโอเคก็เดี๋ยวตอน
นี้เนี่ยเวลาหมดแล้วกับข้างหน้าเนี่ยก็
ครูเตรียมก็เอาเรื่องอะไรมาเล่าให้ฟังเรา
ก็มาคุยกันได้เลยค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้ต้องลาไป
ก่อนแล้วค่ะโซนิคออกไปแล้วโอเคครับไว้
สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายน